mains tachées qu'il y ait les yeux
bandés ou assis dans un fauteuil roulant
le temps d'une journée les valides ont
pu ressentir le quotidien des personnes
handicapées
lors de la dernière journée de la
semaine du handicap organisée par
montigny le bretonneux physique en
passant par la porte c'est pas c'est dur
et pourvoit les personnes est toujours
en fauteuil roulant cela doit être dur
c'est bien oui que tout le monde puisse
un jour se dire moi je j'ai la chance de
pouvoir remarcher de d'être en bonne
santé bouclant comment d'autres
personnes peuvent vivre au quotidien ce
qui pour nous semble si facile
le défi le plus complexe était
certainement en 10 20 tenté d'escalader
avec un handicap artificiel mais les
valides avez la chance d'être accompagné
par les membres de l'équipe de france
d'escaladé handisport malvoyantes de
naissance roxane ailier a décidé de
grimper au haut niveau il ya quatre ans
et sa passion elle a dû la prendre au
gré des parois quand on est mal voyance
un peu c'est l'un des sports vers
lesquels on ne dirige et j'en avais fait
quand j'étais en classe découverte en
école primaire nos écoles spécialisées
qui après au lycée
c'est spécialisés et une fois que j'ai
fini j'ai eu fini lisse et je me suis
dirigé vers le club compte bien il faut
que je sois guider donc quelqu'un va me
dire d'aller où sont les prises et ça ça
s'acquiert à force d'expérience il ya
quelques semaines l'équipe de france
d'escaladé handisport a glané deux
médailles aux championnats du monde qui
se sont déroulés à paris
comme quoi avec un handicap on peut
comme gravir des montagnes
ça m'a permis de m'ouvrir et c'est ce
que j'essaie de faire justement et c'est
andy grimper ses filles et tout ce que
je fais dans ma vie de tous les jours
c'est qu'on arrête de se prendre la tête
voir la vie avait vachement tout simple
que ça